there's a gay who gazed so hard he's gay
[Laughter]
all right guys that's the end of the
video that's the video no here we go all
right three two
[Music]
there is a type of Japanese beef that is
so popular there's a 30-year wait list
have you heard of this it's probably
like do you already have Kobe beef and
it's probably the Kobe of the Kobe beef
it is for it is frozen Kobe beef in
croquette form oh wow
which is a family-run butcher shop and
like help
yeah yeah
City in Western Japan hyogo prefecture
yeah if you ever want to stop Steve we
make it reads 30 years what's that word
sensation oh thank you yeah okay so yeah
so a chrome kit yeah that's like uh
those fried potato
it's like Japanese hash browns it's like
mashed potato in the middle and it's
battered so this place I said a
croquette is a Japanese hash brown
this place was founded in 1926. they
sold meat products from uh Hugo Hugo
oh
um my wife's half asian give me a break
Kobe beef included for decades So like
um Kobe beef beef foods for decades
before adding these beef Croquettes to
the Shelf in the Years following World
War II but it was until the early 2000s
that these deep fried potato and beef
dumplings became an internet sensation
resulting in the ridiculously long
weight that fires now face kids so like
we're talking you order it right now and
you gotta wait
quite a [__] long time see you know
why this happens what
because in Japan they find the most
complicated ways to do the simplest [__]
and the reason why things take forever
is because they don't want to hire new
people yeah they keep it in the family
and then put those in the right way
handmade you know it's the best [__]
though but they're like the diamond
industry where they build the hype and
then they refuse to change so they
control Supply
dude I waited a whole year and a half
for a pair of boxing mitts that this old
Japanese man makes is it the hype the
it's called winning winning I gave you a
pair of the small ones yeah but it's a
pair of mitts that I had to get custom
made and it took them a year and a half
to make it and it came from all the way
from Kyoto because I bet you they only
have three employees that's been working
there since the 80s dude but it's the
best [__] it's the best [__] Floyd
Mayweather gets all this [__] from him
do you watch them go like this while you
got knocked out
because you're waiting but I look at the
gloves I'm like man those are sweet whoa
these are sweet gloves are we worth it
oh man at least these are cool they do
they have that too for uh for [__]
golf irons they have like them in Japan
you get the most expensive golf irons
all of them are [__] handmade you
have to be like working at that company
to be a specific like uh you know
Creator or artist that like makes them
and like fine tunes them yourself like
weighs them out and everything like that
and take forever to make and each club's
like over a thousand dollars you're
gonna get them same [__] [__] no yeah
you are maybe one day when Luna hits it
baby
uh I don't know do you know what happens
when that oh no we'll talk later we'll
talk after it
um it
they had to stop selling them in 2016
outright because the waiting time became
over 14 years and they were thinking
about stopping orders but they got so
many calls who were complaining about
doing that that they're like fine [__]
it we'll make a bigger list I wonder if
the pre-sell is like 20 bucks because
they
each time we raise the price who JPY 500
which is like five bucks three no three
and a half quarter dollars yeah
um or like between three and a half and
four dollars with the consumption tax
and then but since the the export of
Kobe beef begun the price of beef have
doubled so that that also hindered the
production of the Croquettes but
you put up five you put like less than
five bucks down for a 30 year old hold
isn't that funny like just raise your
prices more dude
get the pre-sales man you would just
forget about it by that time oh that's
true or you might die which one's gonna
die which who's gonna die before you
even try it which your kids can inherit
your 30 year away and they can eat it so
you're [__] securing these for your
future that experience that is a dumb
system right it's wild dude it's like
NFL season tickets like your your
family's on the list dude for life but
then by then we'll probably have beef
two or three yeah how would you run it
if that was your business well what's
the I'd hire a ton of Chinese folks that
could make it in 30 seconds because
Chinese people are fast Japanese people
are slow they don't like [__] working
dudes
they like take breaks too much really
look at a sushi restaurant they're only
open for [__] lunch and dinner what
kind of breaks they take is it smoke
breaks they yeah they're probably
pounding like a pound like a bunch of
alcohol and then a pack of cigarettes
and then they go all right now it's time
to work so what is the story behind what
makes Japanese restaurants have that
closed Gap uh cleaning and prepping
fresh ingredients yeah they're like such
a Japanese thing how come it's not like
I think it's like what's the point of
serving in the middle if all of your
rushes are happening in these two times
and in the middle you could just prep
better so then every single time are
they prepping though because I see every
single time I try to go to Japanese
restaurant like oh [__] they're closing
this time I see the guy's just like
sleeping
maybe sleep recharging because that
seems funny to me that if they're open
in a western culture place that kind of
wouldn't that be sort of
counterproductive I don't know the sushi
restaurants are notorious for like doing
their own thing right they're just like
you come into my house I'm gonna just
that's where the omakasa is like it's
like what do you want no what do I want
to make for you for some reason pay me
220 bucks I'm making you something you
don't know [__] you know I feel like
when I see a Japanese restaurant that
takes a little midday break I go oh
they're legit
no it's true oh they got some high
quality [__] dude so um do you guys
remember when the new Star Wars movie
the first one was coming out with like
Harrison Ford back and all this stuff
and like there was like a guy who was
terminally ill and he reaches out he's
like hey can I just see your [__]
because I'm not gonna make it and they
like show him a bunch of footage and
[__] like that you know he dies no no no
he yeah he thought it sucked no I'm
kidding no but but that's kind of like
how this is for people there's a guy who
had
um cancer and he was on the waitlist for
these this meat these croquettes and he
he reaches out the restaurant he's like
I just want you to know that you guys
are getting me through my surgeries and
through like when I'm going through
because I'm so looking forward to having
some of this [__] and they still didn't
bump him up on the [__] list yeah
dude you gotta wait bro dude rules are
rules man that's kind of what's up
though isn't that [__] a horse that's
high quality dude it's kind of tight
number 500 on the list for a reason well
maybe they don't even want to give it to
them at all because they're like your
taste buds are probably not
no or or they're like hey let's not bump
him up let's push him back so he lives
longer for it
a lot of that's good that's motivation a
lot of the high quality like
craftsmanships though is dying because
of how labor intensive is so like they
were doing they do a lot of stories
about like how people maintain like
let's say tofu making or soy sauce
making or all these different OG crafts
that are handmade it's been in the
family for like let's say over 100 years
same family keeps it together and they
pass it down right but the thing is
modern society so like instant and like
also the payoff sucks so this tofu maker
he took over the business from his dad
he's already in his like
early 60s late 50s his kids didn't want
to take it and he was showing the
process he has to wake up at like four
in the morning all this [__] he makes
like a couple blocks of tofu and he
makes like 20 to 30 grand a year
and then he's like yeah obviously no
one's going to want to do this they're
going to want to get an education and
they could make double what I do working
for a company
so he's like
why should people want to continue the
craftsmanship in Japan so it's For the
Love of the Game that's one part of it
but then a lot of them you know the the
towns are getting deserted too so
there's a lot of ghost towns now because
like they're also not um repopulating
enough so like they're doing all like
the craftsmanship is dying so that's
what sucks because there's a lot of dope
[__] out there yeah yeah but then the
the families aren't taking it over it's
also it's like that one guy who knows
how to machine a perfect sphere have you
seen that dude no he said like he um
it's like a family passed down skill he
can make a perfect sphere out of what
metal or whatever the [__] he just has
this technique that it takes forever to
learn it but no one else wants to learn
it from him because he's like you can
just make it with another machine in a
second and no wonder the Ancient Aliens
guys can't figure out the ancient the
ancient Egyptians couldn't make it look
it's fear there's no way to do it with
machine tooling you couldn't do it but
he did it with his hands yeah this guy's
like I could teach people and then like
but that's everything it's like
blacksmithing for a lot of things
there's like tons of things you can't
make anymore by hand because it's like
why you know and then how long
blacksmithing is cool though you know it
is cool there are still dudes but like
blacksmithing itself has like 50 000
different ways to make [__] and not all
of them are still around like very few
of them all right dude what a bummer
imagine you like you'd spent your whole
life trying to make the perfect sphere
but no one's like well that's why it was
a [__] that's why it breaks their heart
when their next of kin is not interested
because that's the only person that
might have done it and if they're just
like I want to go be a doctor no
but the sphere
it won't live on yeah oh there was
another cool uh dying art so you know
those plastic food displays that they
have at like Japanese restaurants oh
yeah yeah this guy makes a bunch of dope
ones right but like to what's buying
them anymore plastic plastic like you
know when you see those Ramen bowls or
like curry rice bowls and it's like all
plastic food art but they look good yeah
they look good and we can make this into
a refrigerator magnet like that's
probably the only thing else you're
gonna do with that yeah but no one's
doing that [__] or like buying it
anymore as much yeah that makes sense
yeah sucks do you guys want to end on
that yeah
[Music]